Is there, of course, is
other news this morning.
This on Donald Trump in a search
for ruling against him.
Let's bring in CNN's
Brynn Gingras for that, Brynn.
Yeah,
I mean, a huge ruling
that happened, John.
Basically,
Trump's
empire is shrinking
just a little bit because of this ruling.
Let me get into it.
Basically, yesterday, a New York judge
saying that Trump and his two sons
overinflated their assets
in order to get loans.
Some of those assets, of course,
we know about the golf courses
we know about his hotels.
We know about his homes.
Let me give you a tangible example
of what was in this court ruling.
If you think about his triplex
in Trump Tower, here in New York City.
According to this ruling,
Trump said that it's three times bigger
and square footage
than it actually is over
evaluating the estimation of it by 114
to $207 million, according to this judge,
who didn't mince words and said,
too, that a discrepancy
of this order of magnitude
of magnified by a real estate developer
sizing up his own living
space of decades
can only be considered a fraud.
Now what happens next?
Well, part of this ruling,
the judge
basically canceled the business
certificates of
part of Trump Organization,
and that is defendants in this case
And basically
that means
there's commercial real estate
here on Wall Street,
also a family compound in western
New York,
which will be dissolved,
according to this judge.
There will be a receiver
put in place
who will work out the dissolving
of those properties.
So this is a big blow to Trump,
who, of course,
has always talked about his wealth
and the fact that he is a very rich man.
And that's,
you know,
something he would say
on the campaign trail
as he was getting into into politics.
But certainly
this is something he's not happy about.
Let me read you
what he said in reaction to this judge's
ruling on Andrew Social.
It says, It is a great company
that has been slandered
and maligned
by this politically motivated witch
hunt is very unfair.
And I will call for help
from the highest courts in New York state
or the federal system to intercede.
This is not America.
Now, this all coming
just a week
before the civil trial
was hits
and other claims that were filed
by the New York attorney general.
I get started,
but there as you can
imagine, John,
our appeals
and in play right now
from Trump, from his attorneys.
So one of them, we're expecting a ruling
sometime this week.
So to be determined
if that civil case gets started
as it is expected to on Monday John.
All right, Brigid Grass,
thank you very much.
I want to bring in once again former U.S.
attorney Harry Litman.
So he's had his certificates
pulled, stripped of control
of some of the various Trump companies.
How big of a deal is that, Harry?
Huge if it holds up.
There will be appeals.
As Brant says,
it is a
sledgehammer to Trump
and the entire organized nation
in New York,
including commercial properties
on 40 Wall Street.
As of as when that holds up,
if it's a firm
Trump organization, no longer
exists and may not do business in
New York.
Now, there may be
some kind of you know, it's
very complicated to dissolve a company.
Maybe there is
there's different kinds of corporate
little twists and turns
that leave them with something.
But basically for him and his two sons,
he they are as out of business.
And the thing that matters most to them
it's a death penalty
for the brand
which, you know,
next only to his liberty
is about the worst thing that can happen.
So appeals will run.
But the finding is very strong.
$2.2 billion.
Of inflation over this period.
The attorney general wants 250 million.
But many other people
say appoint
a receiver could wind up
getting at the money is just gone
and distributed to others
with no oversight by Trump
as to where it goes they have to appoint
an independent person.
Is that the brand.
And you say
if it holds up you've read through this.
Yes.
How much of a chance is there that
he could wiggle out of this
I don't see a lot.
He's doing two things.
He's personally sued the judge.
I see that going nowhere.
And then there's the actual fraud
but it will be based on the facts
and the facts.
But the justice and Garon
laid out of
time after time
where he says
he lives in the fantasy world.
This is not a subjective difference,
as Bryn
says, 30,000 feet versus 30,000 square
meters versus 10,000.
That's just a lie.
Same thing
with the valuations
by factors of 200, not two.
I think this case is very strong
and the only issue might be
should the penalty be different
but that standard New York law,
as I understand it,
he is in a world of hurt.
On the business
side, stronger
so far than anything that's happened
on the criminal side.
It's so interesting.
This is a bit of a sleeper case.
Not a lot of people
watching it quite as closely.
But yes, in the end, it could hit a hit.
It hit him harder almost than anything.
Harry Litman, thank you so much.
For your analysis.
David Cay Johnston is with us.
He's an investigative reporter.
You'll remember him
as one of the first
to see Trump's tax returns.
He's also the author of The Big Cheat
How Donald Trump
Fleeced America and Enriched Himself
and His Family.
That book titled
David, is very apropos
to what we're looking at right now.
Can you explain for people
watching at home
why why this actually matters,
that if you did these things,
you know, why does that give him
an uneven playing field with
basically everyone else
Well, by claiming
that his assets were worth two for ten
and more times
than that, their actual value,
Trump received
benefits in the form
of bank loan terms and other matters.
And the judge,
in a very carefully
written 35 page
opinion, walks through this
shows that Trump had asserted that, oh,
nobody pays any attention
to my financial statements.
Everybody knows that they're nonsense
and said, Sorry,
the world doesn't work that way.
In the real world.
And Trump then argued, Well,
I don't have to make any restitution.
And the judge said,
This is not about restitution.
It's about disgorgement.
What I'll be teaching
my law students in the spring
is this analog to it, analogy to it.
You take $100 from the till
and your employer
when it closes,
you go to the racetrack,
you win a thousand,
you put the hundred dollars back.
Not only did you commit a crime,
even though the business was closed,
all the money was gone,
but you have to disgorge the $900 gain
from your winning bet.
And that's what's happening here.
And the judge had given
the Trump companies the death penalty
Donald Trump, as of right
now, is no longer
a businessman in New York.
David,
just to kind of zero in on
some of the specific examples.
I think it's important to actually detail
some of this, you know one in particular
the Trump
filing and 30,000 square
feet for the Trump Tower penthouse value.
The actual size is actually 10,996
square feet
The overvaluation was estimated
to be between 113 and $207 million.
That's not small money here.
That's just one example.
I guess when you listen to the Trump
lawyers or their defense here,
this is how things operated.
I didn't believe that
this was any different
than how anybody else at my level
was operating.
How egregious is something like that
in terms of the world
in which he was operating
and business wise?
Well, Trump is not the only person
to inflate his assets,
but the judge points out
when I'm talking about minor
discrepancies, an extra 10%
or something, we're talking about
massive discrepancies.
And Trump has been doing this
for the whole 35 years
that I have been covering him.
He just makes it up.
And that's why the judge
not only held
that all of Trump's business
licenses are canceled
but he fined five of the Trump lawyers
70 $500 each
for making up false arguments,
for stating the law, said things
that it said
the opposite,
and other misconduct on Donald's behalf.
This is just finally a ruling
against Trump
and his sons,
not Ivanka Trump,
who was involved in business.
Can you explain to people why
involved he
got herself removed from this case?
So it's Donald, his two older
sons, Allen Weisselberg,
and I think
two other employees
of the Trump Organization.
And in New York,
you cannot operate a business
except as a sole proprietor like my book
writing business,
unless you have a license from the state.
And the judge has canceled
all of those licenses,
all of which fall under the umbrella
of the Trump Organization.
This is a corporate death penalty.
Wouldn't you?
You've written so much
not just about kind of the in the weeds
financial dynamics,
but also the man himself.
What do you think this means?
The death penalty
that you're laying out here?
What would this mean
to somebody like Trump?
Well, Donald
potentially can end up with nothing
but his presidential and television
show tensions
eventually after he
appeals, which he will.
And, of course, for his whole life,
they'll insist
he did nothing wrong
because Donald has said in his whole life
he has never done
a single thing that requires
seeking forgiveness.
Those assets will be seized.
They will be sold.
And clearly,
they will not bring the highest prices,
creditors, the fines
due to the state and taxes paid for them.
If there's anything left,
Donald will get that money.
But since he inflated
assets, it's not like much, if anything.
Phil, David Cay Johnston, thank you for
your expertize this morning.